the chair of the Nevada athletic
commission attacked Clark County Sheriff
Joe Lombardo during today's meeting and
threatened him with potential charges
this all stemming from the death of a 20
year old UNLV Student during a charity
boxing match
Nevada athletic commission chairman
Stephen kubeck saying he was going to
ask Clark County Sheriff Joe Lombardo to
testify about the police investigation
into the death of Nathan Valencia the
UNLV Student seen here in red headgear
he collapsed after his unsanctioned
match in November of 2021 and died from
head injuries as our 8 news now
investigators first reported an
investigation by the Attorney General's
office released in August says Metro
Police failed to look into whether Foul
Play was involved and instead Metro only
investigated if where the event was
staged had a proper license cluebek says
he wants more testimony from Metro about
its investigation into Valencia's
opponent in the match Emanuel ailment
investigators say they were able to
examine all gear used at the event
except for hits you know what I was
hands were wrapped we don't know if he
was on any kind of illicit substances I
don't know because nobody did any drug
tests instead of appearing in person
Lombardo sent a letter to the board
calling klubex conduct at the last
meeting on professional and saying quote
it appears that there is no intention to
conduct this meeting any differently
while the sheriff appreciates the work
of the board
doubtful klubeck is a large Democratic
donor and supporter of Democratic
governor Steve sisilak Lombardo is
sisalak's Republican Challenger in the
governor race klubek says he will ask
the Attorney General's office about
potential charges against Lombardo you
can't lie to the commission that's
perjury
perjury when you lie to a state agency
or a court that's perjury
people do go to jail for that for now
those questions about the gloves ailment
we're wearing are still going unanswered
attorney general Aaron Ford's office did
not comment